there's an amazing sculpture of a boxing
ring on an angle and it's to the boxing
Legend named Johannes trollman who was
very popular in German circles as a
great boxing Legend he sort of was using
the Muhammad Ali technique of being
highly athletic rather than just large
and powerful and he was very good
looking swarthy complexion he fought in
Germany and the Nazis made you know
there was a decision against him and the
crowd was having none of it because they
knew boxing the Nazis were faced with
the idea that this was not going down
and so they said okay we're going to
change the rules to neutralize this
guy's style so he divorces his wife to
save her life he covers himself his dark
skin with flower to mock the Aryan
preoccupation with pure and he loses and
this guy gets sent to a camp they're
using him to train other people to put
on exhibitions and finally they can't
take anymore they just forget whether he
got a hoe in the back of his head or a
single bullet but it took us until
recently to reinstate his boxing
championship that was taken away